-Welcome back.
-Thank you for having me.
-I am so happy to have you.
And congratulations.
You were nominated for
three Golden Globe awards,
a couple for "Sharp Objects" --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-And one for "Vice."
On a morning like that,
do you celebrate?
Are you good at celebrating?
-I'm really bad at celebrating.
-Gotcha.
-Or at appropriate times.
Like, I'll just like celebrate
a Tuesday night.
But -- no, I always get
a little uncomfortable
having self celebrations,
me parties.
-Yeah. I guess that makes sense.
-It's a Muppet reference
for you guys.
[ Laughter ]
-But that's very honest of you
to say.
-Yeah. I mean, I'm really
grateful and thrilled.
I just -- yeah.
-Yeah.
I feel like -- yeah.
A celebration for
the nomination,
that's just Jinx City, you know,
once you do that.
This is -- Congratulations.
Such a fantastic portrayal.
Obviously you're playing
a real person, Lynne Cheney.
But I heard you also based it,
not only on her,
but on your grandmother.
-On my grandmother.
-How did you come to that?
-Well, as I started
researching her,
there was something in her voice
and something that sort of
started to remind me
of my grandmother.
And the more I did research --
my grandma is from Utah.
I understand we have
some Utah folks here today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
There was just something
in the way she was raised.
My grandmother
was raised on a farm.
There was a pioneering spirit.
So, yeah.
My grandma was -- she was tough.
Like, she told it how it was.
There was no sugar-coating it.
-This is probably
why you don't celebrate.
[ Laughter ]
Golden Globe nominations.
-No, I mean, when we would go
over to her house,
and it was the idea that the
kids would help out, you know?
So we would, like,
clean cans in the --
There was no, like,
Grandma spoiling you.
-Wow!
-Which I was used to.
So I didn't know that --
-After you cleaned a can,
what would you use it for?
[ Laughter ]
-You would put it back up
with all the other cans
in the cupboard.
But, no.
She was great, but tough.
Yeah. We did a lot of --
-A lot of chores?
-A lot of chores.
-You got worked hard?
-We got worked hard
at Grandma's house, yeah.
So I guess something
about the work ethic
that was instilled
reminded me of Lynne Cheney.
-And obviously a lot's being
talked about
Christian Bale's transformation
into Dick Cheney.
But you also had to
spend a ton of time
in hair and makeup
for this role.
How do you pass time when you
have one of these parts
where you spend so much time
doing that element?
-I found different ways.
I mean, we would -- Christian
often had headphones on.
I would often sing
as Lynne Cheney, which was fun.
-What sort of songs would
your Lynne Cheney sing?
-Mostly hits from the '80s.
-Okay.
-Like "Pour Some Sugar on Me."
-Gotcha.
Now, this sounds like a song
maybe Lynne Cheney
wouldn't be a fan of.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think she would.
-Yeah.
-But it was fun. I would --
♪♪ Pour some sugar on me ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
You know --
♪♪ In the name of love ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, pour some ♪♪
You know, that kind of --
[ Laughter ]
And I have a big regret that
I didn't actually record this
for Adam McKay, because I would
often torture him with
Lynne Cheney
sings hits from the '80s.
-Yeah.
Adam McKay, of course,
is the director of this film.
Director of, among other films,
"The Big Short."
-Yes.
-This is a case where he is
making a movie about someone
whose politics
are divergent from his.
-Yes.
-Were there times -- I have
heard that you would actually
argue with Adam on set
as Lynne Cheney.
-As Lynne Cheney. Adam --
[ Light laughter ]
I had a good -- I had a fun time
playing Lynne Cheney.
[ Laughter ]
But she -- Adam likes to do
a lot of improv at times.
And so to stay loose I would
kind of come and just then
argue with him and criticize him
as Lynne Cheney.
[ Laughter ]
Which is so not my personality,
but I would be like,
"You're wearing shorts and you
want me to take you seriously
as an authority figure."
And that sort of thing.
I accused him
of being a socialist.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That sort of thing.
-It seems like --
-You know, light-hearted banter.
Like "how can I respect you"
kind of thing.
-Yes, exactly.
It seemed like
light-hearted banter
might have been
an even more important thing
to bring to "Sharp Objects."
-Yeah.
-This is a very --
I mean, it's a wonderful series.
But it's very dark
subject matter.
-Yeah.
-You weren't just
the star of it.
You were a producer of it.
Did you feel as though it was
your responsibility
to try to bring levity to set?
-I did. You know, it's something
that's really important to me
on set anyway.
Not at the wrong time,
like someone's trying to do
something serious
and I'm, like, tap dancing,
you know, on their coverage.
But when we have time and to
lighten it, I'd like to do that.
I got an ice cream truck
for people on "Sharp Objects."
And then I also brought
a fart machine onto set.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't make anybody else look
like they were doing it.
It was always me.
-Gotcha. Yeah.
-I didn't --
That would be fun though.
-Yeah.
-Next time.
-Yeah, like a ventriloquist
fart machine that can throw it.
-Exactly. That would be amazing.
[ Laughter ]
But like a remote control so it
comes from across the room.
-Put a laser pointer
on someone else's butt
and then it knows exactly
where to throw it.
-Where you want it to go.
That would be great.
-Oh, we got to invent this.
-This could be so fun.
-We're going to make
so much money.
-So much money.